effectivement la consultation à 20 euros
aggravé déficit l'augmentation de ses
honoraires devait s'autofinancer par des
contreparties demandées aux médecins
dans la réalité ça n'a pas du tout été
le cas
brigitte briffaud christophe montel dans
son rapport annuel la cour des comptes
pointe du doigt les honoraires des
médecins
la hausse de leurs tarifs creuse le
déficit de l'assurance maladie de près
de 700 millions d'euros
j'essaie augmentation des honoraires et
professions confondues
elle représente quelque 690 millions
d'euros
on espérait que en contrepartie les
moindres dépenses du l usage plus
fréquent des génériques permettrait au
moins entre en partie de compenser cette
dépense supplémentaire en réalité la
compensation et me un bourg d environ
soit une économie de seulement 70
millions d'euros et pour les médecins
le clé de la consultation 20 euros est
largement justifiée il affirme faire des
efforts et avoir changé leurs pratiques
médicales
c'est vrai que toutes ces réformes qui
en ce qui concerne le meilleur visage de
la visiter en ce qui concerne les
prescriptions de génériques ou voulaient
les remboursements sur le menu le
médicament le moins cher ou quand il
s'agit de médicaments équivalents
ces mesures structurelles donc qu'ils
vont donner leur produire leurs effets
sur plusieurs années c'est après
plusieurs mois de conflit l'an dernier
que les médecins ont finalement obtenu
la revalorisation de la consultation le
18 à 20 euros c'était une promesse
électorale de jacques chirac
un accord conclu en juin 2002 entre
l'assurance maladie et les syndicats et
salué à l'époque par le ministre de la
santé nous reste naturellement à eux
devraient pour dépenser mieux et c'est
je crois le grand chantier qui
devant nous et que je vais entreprendre
dans ce climat de dialogue social et de
confiance
plus d'un an après force est de
constater que le sauvetage de la
sécurité sociale restent encore
largement chantier